Our first guest has been entertaining us
since she was three years old.
Throughout her career, she's been a singer,
a TV host, an author.
Please welcome the incredible icon,
Marie Osmond.
(crowd cheering)
How sweet is everyone?
I'm so excited to talk to you today.
You know Drew,
you and I have so many similarities
and there's not many people who can relate
to the life that we've had.
Even all the things that we've been through,
so this is super fun for me to be able to talk to you.
Are you kidding?
Now you started performing when you were three.
Right.
I was introduced as the youngest Osman brother.
(crowd laughing)
Literally?
Yeah, it was on Andy Williams.
We all kind of got our shot from Andy,
but, it's so interesting,
very much like I have never not worked
a year of my life since then.
I've worked consistently,
whether it was singing in Sweden and performing there,
or doing Japanese commercials or whatever it was.
And I had my first hit record,
I recorded at 12 and a half, Paper Roses,
and at 14 and a half did the pilot for Donnie and Marie
the original variety show and so,
and I have never stopped since.
And I'm so, I feel so blessed.
(Marie laughing)
My God, I love you.
I really, really do
and there's a couple aspects about motherhood
that also really was important for me
and I got excited about talking to you about.
I would love to start with your mother
and ask about how she kept you guys level headed.
She, okay, for example, Donny and Marie.
Okay, I was, I believe I was around 16 years old
and I had come home and you put hours in,
I was doing 15 hours a day, six days a week,
sometimes 18 hours,
working through the child welfare laws
and going to school and learning 350 pages of script
in two and a half days.
And I remember one time I came home
and it was the next day was the taping.
I said, "Mom, I'm so tired.
"I have to get to sleep so that I look good on camera".
And she goes, "Well, you haven't done your chores".
And I said, "Hello, like
"our show is dubbed into 17 languages worldwide.
"And I'm like, you know, Marie Osmond".
And she, that was the worst thing I ever could have said,
'cause she goes, "Oh I see.
"So now you're going to do your chores and the toilets
"and if you make another word complaining,
"I have a lot more for you to do".
And she said, "Because you have to realize that's a job.
"Jobs will come and go.
"This is reality.
"This is what will always be here.
"Now get to work".
And Drew throughout my life this woman,
she said, I'd come home and she'd say,
"Okay, now we're going to learn to make bread.
"Now we're gonna learn to make clothing"
And I'd be like "Mom I have designers and people that sew"
and she goes "Exactly.
"That's why you're going to learn to do it".
And she just,
I mean, she taught me how to gut a fish,
in case I was camping and I needed to cook it.
This woman taught me reality.
My mom told me once she goes, "I don't care if you hate me.
"If you do that means I'm doing a good job".
Yes, yes, yes.
I couldn't agree more
and something else that has to do with mothers,
that I really loved about your story was,
when I had kids of my own,
I felt like, oh my God,
I don't want to pretend to be other people.
My kids need me.
Those 18 hour days no longer seem like a good idea
for me right now.
I've been doing them my whole life, so it was,
I had a luxury of saying,
I'm ready to prioritize my children over work.
Right.
But then I had to earn a living,
so I had to figure stuff out,
but I wanted to find something that felt like a job
that had the hours and being in the same place.
A lot of the things that our other jobs
that just didn't allow.
The fact that you have prioritized your children,
you'll never regret that.
I had to do that with my children too.
That's one of the reasons I went to Vegas for 11 years.
And that was my point,
is that you found a job that put your kids first
and when I heard that, it made me feel like I just,
it made a lot of sense to me
'cause it made me feel
less alone.
And hey,
I didn't make as much on the road
when I was doing all my country touring,
because I took all my kids with me and I have eight.
And so, it's not great for airplane tickets and costs,
but I did it because I love my children.
Also, I was the only breadwinner.
Long story short now,
my oldest is she just turned 19 and she's out of the home,
so it's just me and my husband,
by the way, I remarried my first husband
and so it's like a honeymoon all over again.
And, but now, I wanna go back out on the road.
I'm actually getting ready to do a big symphonic tour.
I just did an album, a 17 song album.
I was doing my research and I was learning about you
and Steve and I marvel at your story.
You guys married in 82
and then separated in 85.
I don't have a monitor.
Before I was born.
Exactly.
And then you remarried in 2011.
Am I getting the years right?
You are, yep.
Phew, okay good.
I love this so much.
I can't even finish,
first of all, is that really the same wedding dress?
It is.
It's this game dress with some laces in the back
to make it a little bigger.
I was just curious,
how did you guys re-find each other?
Well, if you ask him,
he was asked the other day,
"How do you make a marriage work?"
And he said, "Spend 25 years apart".
(Drew and Marie laughing)
It worked.
You know, we were always best friends,
but I think, so really we didn't even plan it.
It was just so bizarre how it happened.
I had moved to Vegas and we had one child together.
Our oldest son, Steven, I said,
"Steven, can you help me move some things in?"
And my son said, "Well, dad's with me.
"Can he come help?"
And my, he had never remarried
and I guess I'm a hard habit to break,
no.
(Marie laughing)
But when we saw each other, I don't know,
I think you have to realize people change,
but some things don't change.
Like the friendship.
We were just soul mates.
So we always had that connection.
Seriously, okay do we hear crazy?
I don't know if we have time for this,
but that wedding dress.
I was married 20 years.
I had no idea where that dress was.
I had moved several times.
I had moved to Vegas.
I didn't pack that dress for Vegas
and I had designed a dress for our wedding
and five days before the wedding,
the lady showed up with it in 75,000 pieces
and I had my cry and I'm not kidding you guys.
I walked out to the car to go to work
and there was a box leaning on my car, an old box
and I look and it was my wedding,
I'm gonna cry.
It was my wedding dress.
Crazy.
To this day, I still don't know where
that dress showed up from
and I swear it was my mom.
I swear.
(upbeat music)